hello everybody in this video you will
learn the structure of an HTML file as
well as a few basic HTML elements I will
walk you through the process of creating
your very first web page and by the end
of the video you will have created a
very basic web page let's get started by
opening up visual studio code and
creating a new file type any sentence
you want into the file such as this is
my first web page and save the file you
can call this file anything you want but
it must have the extension dot HTML at
the end of the name now if you open that
file on Google Chrome you will see your
web browser rendering the sentence you
typed into the HTML file while this
technically works the file we just
created is not actually valid HTML
behind the scenes the browser
surrounding our sentence and valid HTML
tags to see what these tags look like we
will need to open the developer tools of
Google Chrome to do this press ctrl
shift I or command shift I if you are on
a Mac upon doing this you will be
greeted with a fairly complex looking
window the data in these tabs is
extremely useful in certain scenarios
but for this course we will only care
about the information in the elements
tab the elements tab shows us all the
HTML elements our page is composed of
and as you can see our page has three
elements HTML head and body there is
also a fourth element that every HTML
page has and this is called the doctype
the doctype is the first element of an
HTML page and must be the first thing in
the HTML file the doctor tells the
browser which version of HTML you are
using for all of our videos will be
using HTML as our doctype this tells our
browser to use the most up-to-date
version of HTML available the next
element is the HTML element this element
tells the browser that all the code
inside the HTML element is HTML this tag
should contain everything inside of your
HTML file except the doctype and should
come after the doctype the head element
is the next element and is technically
optional the information in the head
element is never displayed in the
browser but is instead used to set
information such as the title or
description of the page this element is
generally the first element inside the
HTML element but it does not have to be
our last element is the body element the
body element contains all the
information that we want to display
inside the browser
this can include text images videos and
much more try updating your HTML file to
include all these elements and also
change the text to something else then
save the file you may notice that Google
Chrome does not update and render your
changes in order to force google chrome
to update you will need to refresh the
browser this can become quite annoying
though
if you must refresh each time you make a
change so will download a plugin for
visual studio code called live server
this plug-in will automatically refresh
our browser every time we make a change
in order to download this plugin go to
the extensions tab in the bottom left of
the sidebar and type the live server
into the search bar next click the
install button on the live server plugin
and then click the reload button after
the install is complete this will
restart visual studio code with the new
plug-in enabled now if you open your
HTML file you will see a go live button
on the bottom of the screen this button
will open your HTML file in your default
browser and every time you save your
HTML file it'll automatically reload
your browser you may notice that the URL
in your browser has changed and now
looks something like this this is
because the live server plugin actually
uses your computer as a server to serve
the files to the web browser on your
computer let's break down with this URL
means the first set of numbers from the
URL 127 dot 0 dot 0 dot 1 is the IP
address of your local host this IP
address is exactly the same on all
computers and is the IP address of the
computer server the second set of
numbers after the colon is the port
number these two numbers work similarly
to how an address of an apartment
complex works the IP address is like the
address of the apartment complex while
the port number represents the apartment
number of a single room in the apartment
complex if you do not specify a port
number the browser will automatically
use port 80 which is the default port
for HTTP communication you now have all
the setup complete to efficiently
develop HTML pages
we'll begin learning new HTML elements
as well as the structure of an HD
we'll also start building the project
that we will work on over the duration
of the entire introduction to web
development course the project is to
create a website for your favorite
musician or band I will walk you through
the exact steps needed to create the
website and I'll explain all the
concepts along the way as you follow
along with this course I want you to
choose your favorite musician or band
and create the website for them instead
of copying exactly what I do in this
video we'll be creating the HTML for the
about page of the fans website you may
notice that it looks ugly now but
remember that hTML is only for the
content of the site later we'll use CSS
to style the page let's get started by
going over the structure of an HTML
element most HTML elements are composed
of a start tag and end tag and some
content between these tags the content
inside these tags can either be text or
other HTML elements there are some tags
however that have no content and thus
have no end tag these are called empty
elements the image tag and is an example
of an empty element as you may notice
the image tag has an attribute called
source all HTML elements can have
attributes set on them to define certain
characteristics of the element such as
the source for an image tag and that is
all there is to an HTML element we will
now jump into the actual coding of the
about page for the website and what
about many different types of HTML
elements hello everybody welcome to the
coding section of this video as you can
see on the left side of my screen I have
Visual Studio code open with the HTML
from the previous video I also have an
images folder containing all of the
images that we're going to be used to
create the about page of this website on
the right of my screen you can see the
final version of the about page created
for a band called the generics for you
this band will be completely different
but you should be able to follow the
same template that I am using on this
right side in order to get started
creating this band page let's first
right click on our about page and click
open with live server this will allow us
see our changes live as we make them now
let's go back to the final band page and
take a look at the different components
of the page the first thing you may
notice is that at the top of the page we
have a header
this header contains a navigation with
three links going to the home page
the store page and the about page as
well as a title for the band the
generics there's also a line in between
the two separating them let me paste in
some code that will render this for us
now let me open this code in the browser
as you can see we have our navigation
links at the top of the page
our title at the bottom and a horizontal
line separating them let me explain how
this works first all of our content is
wrapped with this header tag this header
tag is just a way of telling the browser
this is a header element it doesn't
apply any styling to these elements it
just says this block of code is the
header for our page the next element
inside of our page is the nav of it this
is very similar to the header element in
that it doesn't apply any styling but it
tells the browser that this is the
navigation section of our web page you
could have multiple Navs throughout your
page but most likely you're going to
just have one nav either in the top of
your page or on the side of your page
next we have the UL element
this stands for unordered list there are
two types of lists that you can create
in HTML in Oh L which is an ordered list
and a ul which is an unordered list in
our case we are using an unordered list
or a ul because the elements in our list
have no particular order to them next we
have three li elements li elements
stanford list item and can only be used
inside of a UL or an oo these denote the
actual items of your list and as you can
see on the right are styled with a
bullet point when they're inside of an
unordered list and they are styled with
numbers when they're inside of an
ordered list next we have an HR element
this element as you can see has no
closing tag which means it is an empty
element this HR element supplies us this
horizontal line in our page and stands
for horizontal rule lastly we have an h1
element the h1 element is a heading
element and there's six different sizes
of a chav heading
there's the h1 h2 h3 h4 h5 and h6 each
one is progressively smaller than the
last one with the h1 being the largest
and the age 16 the smallest now let's go
back to our final version of the webpage
and look at the next section of code
that we have this is the About section
at the top you could see that we have a
header element which is called about a
grouping of text with an image and
another group of text
well they pasted over some code that
will define this section and view this
in the browser as you can see we have
that about heading a group in a text our
image and another group in a text on the
left here we can view the actual code
and break it down the first thing you'll
notice is that we have a section element
that wraps all the other code in this
section the section element is very
similar to a header element and then it
implies this is a grouping of stuff that
is all inside of one section while the
header element says this is the header
of our page the section element says
this is just a generic section of some
form in which all the content is related
next we have an h2 element for the about
header this is very similar to our h1
header except for that an h2 header is
always going to be smaller than an h1
header because h1 is the largest header
h6 is the smallest as you remember so h2
is just one step below an h1 and as you
can see on the right here our h1 for the
genetics is larger than our h2 for about
next we have a P element also known as a
paragraph element a paragraph element
defines a grouping of text that is
usually long-form paragraph form text
with many sentences and it is much
smaller font than our headings next we
have an image tag the image tag as you
can see is an empty element and has no
end tag it also has this source
attribute that we talked about earlier
the source attribute defines the path to
the image to be displayed on the page in
relation to the actual page you're on so
as you can see we are in this about HTML
page and in the images folder we have an
image called bandmembers PNG
so in order to get this image we go into
the images folder and then get the image
bandmembers dot PNG this must be a path
related to the about HTML file so if we
move to this about HTML file into our
images folder for example then this path
would have to be bandmembers dot PNG as
opposed to images slash bandmembers dot
PNG and if we reopen this in live server
you'll see that this now works let's
move that back to where it was them and
then make this images slash bandmember
top PNG and open it in live server again
and there we go the image works now and
lastly we have another paragraph element
with another section of text now let's
go back to our final page and look at
the last element that we have the footer
element as you can see in the footer we
have the generics heading as well as a
YouTube image of Spotify image and a
Facebook image let me paste over some
code that will define this in HTML and
view this in the browser as you can see
we have that heading as well as our
three images if we go over and look at
the actual HTML code you'll notice that
almost all the elements are something
that we've already used before the
footer element just like the header at
section element defines a grouping of
text and HTML that is going to be in the
footer of the page which is almost
always going to be at the very bottom of
your page we then have our h3 element
which just like the h2 and h1 is a large
text heading for the page and it is
going to be smaller than the h2 element
we then have another unordered list with
three list items in it and each one has
an image which links to the Facebook
logo Spotify logo and YouTube logo in
our images folder and that's all there
is to creating the HTML for this about
page as you may notice our actual final
page looks very different than what our
current page looks like but that is
because this final page is styled using
CSS as you remember from earlier videos
HTML is only used to define the content
of the page and this right here is all
of the content
to our page the styling for the fonts
font size background colors and all
these images that will all come later in
CSS all the content though the HTML is
complete for this about page some common
problems that you may run into as you
create the HTML for your own band about
page is that you forget to include the
ending tag for your HTML elements if you
do this your HTML will not look correct
or it may not even render at all in
order to check that you have created all
the ending tags for your HTML elements
if you click on either the start type or
the end tag Visual Studio code will
automatically highlight the ending tag
for you or the start tag if you selected
the ending tag this is an easy way to
check if you have actually created the
ending tags and starting tags for all of
your elements another common problem is
with your images not displaying in order
to get around this problem make sure
that the path for your image is in
relation to your actual HTML page that
it is on for example our about page is
in the same folder as the images folder
so we must first navigate through the
images folder to get to the images
inside of it
we'll dive into more HTML elements as we
build the homepage of the band website
and by the end of this video we'll have
created all of the HTML needed for the
homepage of our website before we get
started coding let's cover a few of the
concepts that we will be utilizing
starting with HTML elements if you have
ever tried to use a greater than or less
than sign in the text of your HTML you
may notice that it does not render and
actually messes with your entire page
rendering this is because these symbols
along with many more are special symbols
that are used in HTML for signifying
start and end tags in order to render
these symbols we must use HTML entities
an HTML entity is written by writing an
ampersand and pound sign followed by the
number that corresponds to the symbol
for example this is the code that will
render the less than symbol remember in
which numbers correspond to which
symbols can be quite difficult though
this is why the most common symbols such
as the less than sign have a name that
can be used instead of the number this
is the code for the less than symbol
using the name as opposed to the number
when you use the name of this symbol
instead of the number make sure that you
do not include the pound sign after the
ampersand the next major concept is the
idea of meaningless elements so far we
have only learned about elements that
have inherit meaning for example the
header element is used to wrap the
header of a page the nav element is from
the navigation section and the ha1
element is for a heading HTML has many
many elements that have specific meaning
but sometimes a section of your page do
not have any special meaning or there is
no HTML that conveys the meaning you
want this is where meaningless elements
come in there are two different
meaningless elements div and span these
elements are the same in every way
except that the div element is a block
element meaning that it will appear on a
separate line from the content around it
similar to the paragraph tag the span
element on the other hand is an inline
element and thus appears in line with
the content around it if this does not
make sense yet the differences between
these two elements will become apparent
as we write the HTML for this lesson
essentially all you need to know about
meaningless elements is that they should
be used anytime you need to group
together HTML that either has no meaning
or there is no HTML tag to describe the
meaning now that we got that other way
or
jump into the coding of the homepage for
the band website hello everybody welcome
to the coding section of this video as
you can see on the Left I have Visual
Studio code open with the project we
left off in the last video and on the
right I had the final version of the
band home page to get started we should
copy the about HTML page and rename it
to index.html this is because the about
page shares the same header and the same
footer as our home page we now can get
rid of the section in the middle that
contains the about content since we will
not need that on the home page the
reason that we named this page
index.html is because the index page is
the page that is shown when you leave
nothing after the website URL so we
removed this slash index.html and hit
enter you'll see that it renders the
exact same thing that is inside the
index.html
if we change this save it you'll see it
shows up there now let's get started
with the actual content of this page
let's jump back to the image that we
have to use as a reference and get
started with the header as you can see
inside the header we have an additional
button for guitar lay at the latest
album and another button for the play
button to create these elements we'll
use the button element the button
element will render a button on the page
as we can see here and if we give it
some text such as what is on this page
you get our latest album you'll see that
it renders a button that we can click on
our page let's do the same exact thing
for the play button now we can't
actually just show this image with a
normal button keypress we have to use an
HTML entity that we talked about earlier
the code for this entity is as follows
this will render the play button as we
can see here as you may notice our two
buttons on this same line as opposed to
on different lines like they are in this
image this is because the button is an
inline element as opposed to a block
element in order to get around this
problem we can use a tag called the line
break tag which is the BR tag the BR tag
adds a line break wherever it is so if
we put it after this button it'll create
a line break right here
before the next button and if we save
that on the right you can see that they
are on separate lines now we want a
little bit more spacing than this
between our elements so I'll use another
line break element in order to create a
little bit of a gap between our two
buttons that is all the HTML that we are
going to need for the header section but
as you can see in this home page view
that there is a giant background image
that is applied for the entire header in
order to remind us that we need to
create this background image and find it
later let's add a comment into the code
to do this use an exclamation point
followed by two dashes which will create
a comment in the code comments do not
actually render any information on the
HTML page but they show up in the code
so that you can remind yourself or other
people that use this code what certain
things mean or what to do so for example
let's create just a to do comment that
tells us that we need to find a suitable
background image there we go so now if
we go back to our page you can see that
that does not actually render but it
shows up in the code for us to reference
later now let's go on to the middle
section of our page in the middle of
section of our page we will use a
section element just as we did for the
About section of our code to wrap all of
this stuff in our tours section and you
can see that we have a header called
tours just like we had in the About
section so let's create an h2 and add
the text tours into that and view that
to make sure that that shows up
correctly next we have a few rows that
display all the tour dates for our
upcoming tours of the generics band
there is no actual HTML element to
denote a row for example in this
scenario so what we are going to do is
we are going to wrap our entire set of
rows in a div which is a meaningless
element that we talked about earlier
this will make it a block element so
that way these items will not appear on
the exact same line as each other we
will then wrap each individual row in a
divot of its own so this outside div
here is wrapping all of these rows and
then each one of these rows has its own
div that will contain just the text
inside of it now let me add the text
inside of the rows now as you can see if
we go over to our page we have the
different text rendered for all the text
in the row but it doesn't quite look
right first off we need this July 16th
date to be bolded in order to do this in
HTML we will use what's called a strong
tag the strong tag denotes something
that is important in most cases it means
that the text inside of the strong tags
will be bolded but in some scenarios the
text will actually not be bolded for
example if you are using a screen reader
if you are blind the text will have
special emphasis when it speaks it back
to you because you cannot actually see
bold versus non vult
let's put our July 16th inside of that
strong tag save it and go back to our
browser to see that that is actually
bolded now next we have the text for
Detroit and the text for the actual
place that the performance is in let's
wrap these in span tags span tags are
the other meaning this element that we
talked about and this denotes an inline
element if we go to our rendered version
of our page you can see that these
elements do not break the lines as these
bakka elements from the div do if we
were to change this to be a div you can
see that now it breaks both on the top
and the bottom of the line let's change
that back to a span lastly we need to
create the button for our final element
let's wrap this by tickets
text inside of a button element now if
we go back to our page we can see that
that is now a clickable button one more
thing to note about these buttons is
that they can have a type to them which
is an HTML attribute
in this case you can have the type the
button menu reset or submit in our case
since this is just a generic button we
want to use the button type let's copy
that and paste that into our other
buttons as well since they are also
generic buttons lastly we need to add an
HR element that we talked about in the
previous video to the end of our row
because we have this underline here that
we want to incorporate now if we go back
we can see that we have this underline
under our row you may notice that the
text is very close together with almost
no space in between them you may think
that in order to fix this you can add a
bunch of spaces after your text and if
you say that you would think that a
bunch of spaces are show up after this
but if you say but you see that that
does not happen
HTML actually removes all of the extra
spaces after any element whether it's a
space a tab even if you put an enter a
new line in here and say that it'll
remove all of those at the end of your
element in order to get around this and
actually include some space in between
our elements we are going to use to use
temporary the less-than and greater-than
symbols that we talked about earlier
with the HTML entities let's go after
our strong tag here and write the code
for less then and a code for greater
than now you can see that we have a
little bit of a space between our text
let's copy and paste this in between all
of the different elements of the row and
now there's a little bit of spacing so
that it's easier to see which element is
which the last thing that we need to do
in order to get our page to be exactly
the same as this is copy this row and
create all the text needed for the rest
of these rows I'm gonna do that real
quick now
we now have all the code that we need
for these sections if we go back to this
page we can see that all of our rows are
now being rendered and they all look
correct except you see that we have this
additional underline on the last row so
go back to our code and remove that
final HR element now we have exactly the
same HTML that we have on this page the
last thing we should do is delete this
placeholder text that we added in here
at the beginning and now we are perfect
the only thing left to do is to add some
it elements to the head as you can see
at the top this title of our page is
just shows the URL of the page that we
are on if we want to change that we can
use a title element in the head section
of our HTML this will actually not show
up anywhere on the body of our page but
it will be used by the browser to set
the title of our page on the tab let's
just set the title to the generics and
if we save you can see that now it group
race is the title of our page another
common element in the head section is a
meta tag the meta tag has a bunch of
different things that we can define for
it based on what we set for the name
attribute but in our case we want to set
the description of our page this
description is used by the browser to
show a little bit of a description of
your page under the title whenever you
search in Google for example along with
other places for us let's just set any
title which we set inside of the content
section of this tag let's just say this
is the description and close off that
meta tag now as you see when we save
nothing actually changes on our page
because this is inside of the head of
our page if we would have upload this
page to the Internet and do a Google
search for it you'll see that this
description will show up underneath the
title of our page inside of the Google
browser results now let's go to our
about page and do the exact same thing
sided ahead just paste this in here
change the title from generics to the
other generics about and we can keep the
description exactly the same that's all
that there is to creating the HTML for
our index page
we'll dive into one more crucial HTML
element as we build the store page of
the band website by the end of this
we'll have created all the HTML that we
need for the entire project before we
get started coding we need to cover one
of the most important and most common
HTML elements the anchor tag the anchor
tag also known as the a tag is the HTML
element that allows us to add links to
our web pages the structure of the
anchor tag is very similar to that of an
image tag but instead of specifying a
source attribute for an image an anchor
tag uses an href attribute which stands
for hypertext reference the href
attribute works exactly like the source
attribute when trying to find the file
you specified
this means that the href attribute value
should be relative to the HTML file that
the anchor tag is in for example if you
had a file called page HTML in the same
folder as the HTML file with the anchor
tag then you would use page HTML as the
href of the anchor tag to link to page
HTML another use of the href tag is to
link to other web pages by their URL
this also works exactly the same as the
source attribute of the image tag if you
want to create a link to Google then you
would create an anchor tag and set the
href to Google's URL the shoe all must
be the full URL of the website which
includes HTTP at the beginning in order
for an anchor tag to work the href
attribute must be defined another common
attribute the target attribute on the
other hand is optional the target
attribute specifies where the link
should open by default the value of the
target attribute is self which means the
link should open in the current browser
tab
the only other value for the target
attribute is blank that means that the
link opens in a separate tab don't
forget to make sure you include the
underscore in the front of the self and
blank target attribute values or they
will not work we will cover both target
types in the coding section of this
video so if this does not make sense yet
it will become obvious in a bit now that
we got that out of the way let's jump
into the coding of the store page for
the band website
hello everybody welcome to the coded
section of this video as you can see on
the Left I have Visual Studio code open
with the project from the last video
that we left off on the only difference
is that inside the images folder I've
added all the images that we're going to
need to create the store page of the
band website on the right of my screen I
have a picture of the store webpage
pulled up so we can use this as a
reference to create the HTML for the
band page let's get started by copying
the about HTML page and renaming it to
store tout HTML this is because our
store page and our about page both share
the same header and the same footer now
let's delete the content in the center
about the about page that we do not
actually need in the store page what we
do need is we need to create a section
for the music section for merch
intersection for cart let's do that
inside of each of these sections we're
also going to have the header for the
title of music merchant cart now let's
take a look at the content inside of
each of these sections as you can see
the music emerge section both share the
same template for its content where it
has an album or t-shirt or coffee cup
whatever is being sold picture of that
the price of it and then a button to add
it to the cart so let's create these
elements we're going to want to do we're
going to want to wrap this entire
element inside of a div element so that
way we know it is one contained content
inside of that div we're going to want
to have a div for the album name this is
because we want this to be on its own
line so we can't just use a span and
inside of that div since this is bolded
we will use a strong tag to put the
title of album 1 next we're going to
want to add the image tag and it's going
to have a source attribute which in our
case is going to be images slash album 1
dot PNG and lastly we need to add a
final div that's going to wrap both the
price and button for adding to cart
we're going
put the price inside of a span and then
we're going to add the button for Add to
Cart and make sure to add the role of
button since this is just a general
generic button now let's open that up
using live server to see what our
changes look like as you can see we have
the album name picture of the album and
then the line containing the price and
the button to add to cart' the only
thing left to do now is to copy this and
paste it down four times so that we have
the section like this for all the
album's that we are selling in the music
section of our store I'm going to do
that now now if we open that up we can
see that we have our four different
albums being displayed with the title at
the top picture in the middle and price
and button at the bottom you may notice
however though that they are all on an
individual line as opposed to being side
by side as they are in this image this
is because we are wrapping all of them
inside of a div and divs break the line
as we talked about earlier later we are
going to fix this in the CSS portion of
our course but for now we will just keep
it like this because as you remember
hTML is only for content and CSS is
where we talk about way out and display
now if we go back to the image of our
store page we can see that in the merge
section we have almost the exact same
layout that we do inside of the music
section of our store so I'm just going
to copy one of the templates from the
music section paste it into the merged
section and change it accordingly now if
we go view this you'll see that these
also show up at the bottom inside of the
merged section the last thing that we
have to look at is the card section of
our store this is slightly different
than the rest of our sections and
includes a few new elements that we
haven't talked about yet let's first get
started by creating the header row of
item price and a quantity to do this we
will wrap all three of these in a div so
that they appear on the same line and we
will use strong tags
to wrap all the content because it is
bolded now if we go take a look at that
we'll see that we have item price and
quantity all displayed on the same line
but we will use the same spacing trick
that we used in the last video in order
to show the space between these because
right now it is difficult to read so in
our code we are going to add a less than
and greater than sign this will add a
little bit of spacing between our
elements we'll just copy it as Homer
time so it's between price and quantity
as well next we are going to work on
adding in each of the individual rows of
this section we'll do this by using
another div tag throughout the entire
row followed by an image tag to store
the image for the first diagram we'll
use the source to the album one as we
talked about earlier now close that and
we will go look at it and we'll see that
this image is way too large we want this
image to be much smaller in order to do
that we can set a width and height
property on the actual image element
itself this attribute we're going to set
to 100 which will stand for 100 pixels
if we leave off the height element it'll
automatically adjust the height to be an
aspect ratio with the width so if we had
an image that was 200 pixels by 400
pixels so 200 pixels by 400 pixels tall
and we set the width to 100 the new
height would be 200 which would
automatically be set if we however set
both the height and the width it'll
automatically check both those for us to
be 100 and 100 next we're going to want
to add the name of the actual item
instead of a span we will just call this
t-shirt and then we want to add and
Christ instead of a span as well
in between those we're going to want to
use the less-than and greater-than signs
that we talked about for our spacing now
if we view that we'll see that we have
the name of the item followed by the
price of the item next we need to add in
this input that allows users to select
the quantity of item that they want
where they can type in any number that
they want in here
in order to do this we're going to use
an input element an input element is an
empty element that allows us to create
an input of various different types in
this case we are using a number input so
we will set the type equal to number
there are many different types of input
that you can create but the most common
types are a number input and a text
input we will then close that off and if
we go back to our page you will see that
we have an input in here that allows us
to enter only numbers into it we cannot
enter anything that is not a number just
numbers but in our example you can see
that we have this pre-populated with a 1
in order to do this we'll set the value
of property the value property
corresponds to the value of the actual
input element and as we change it as we
type in different numbers into the input
this value will automatically adjust to
be the same as whatever number we typed
in here so over here let's just put the
value of 1 because that is what is in
our picture here I'm also going to use
the same space and tricks that we talked
about the less than greater sign to add
a space between this price and the input
and lastly we need to add in a button
this button will have the role of button
because it is a generic button and
inside of it we will just put the text
remove now if we go back to our page we
can see that we have all the elements
here that we have in our image over here
now it's copy this div one time and fill
it in with the information from the
second row of down here
now if we go back we can see that we
have the correct information here I also
changed this first image to be the shirt
image because I forgot to change that
and as we can see we have the value of 2
in here which corresponds to the value
of the input element here lastly let's
add an HR after all these in order to
put that line at the bottom of the page
that we have here before we get to total
the reason I'm not including an HR under
these item price and quantity views is
because we will add these later with CSS
this is because an HR takes up the
entire space that is given which in our
case will be all the way from the far
left web page to far right of our page
with no breaks in between now let's add
a final div which is going to contain
the information for the total and the
price as we can see the total is
emphasised with bold so we use a strong
tag and type in total and then we will
have the price inside of a span lastly
we want to add this purchase button at
the very bottom underneath of everything
else so which side of a tip of its own
so that it is on its own line we're
adding a button with the role of Clutton
and we will give you the text of
purchase and that's all there is to
creating this HTML here and as we can
see if we look over here we have all the
elements that we have on this page
created in HTML here the last thing we
have left to do is add in links so that
we can navigate with the home store and
about buttons that we have up here in
order to do that let's scroll up to the
very top and wrap this text inside of an
a tag as we talked about earlier so that
now our text is a link but in order for
this link to work we needed the href
that we talked about earlier
since our store page is in the same page
as our index page which is our home page
all we need to type in is index.html and
now when we save this we'll have a link
here that when we click on it will bring
us to the index.html page now let's go
back to the store page and do this for
all of our different links now you can
see that we have buttons for the home
page store page in the about page and
when clicked on to bring us to the
different pages at the very bottom we'll
notice that we also have buttons for
YouTube Spotify and Facebook so now we
need to add anchor tags wrapped around
this but as you can see there's no text
for us to wrap around all there is is
this image tag that is ok we can wrap
this image tag inside of an anchor tag
and it will work as a button in order to
do this create the anchor tag give it a
rich href which in this case is going to
be the URL of YouTube which is HTTP
colon backslash backslash youtube.com
and then we will put the image tag
inside of this a tag and we say that if
you hover over YouTube we can see that
there's a button and if we click it
it'll bring us to youtube.com what's do
the same thing for Spotify and Facebook
now if we save that we see that the
youtube link Spotify link and Facebook
link are all working as you can see if
we click here we go to the Spotify
website and so on but one problem is
that when we click these links it'll
override the tab that we're in and we
don't want that for these bottom links
so we're going to use the target
attribute on our H ref and we're going
to set it to underscore blank I'm going
to copy this over to all the rest of our
links and now when we click on a link
for Spotify for example it'll open in a
new tab while keeping the tab for our
original page now all we need to do is
copy these new links that we created
over to our home and our about page and
our HTML will be completely finished for
the entire website and there we go
now if we go to any of these pages
you'll see that we have links that work
on all of our pages one last thing that
I forgot to mention is that in our store
page we want to change the title of our
page from the generics about to the
generics store and there we go that is
all the HTML that we need for this
entire project in our next set of videos
we'll be covering CSS CSS is what is
going to allow us to take in this boring
lion looking HTML and converting it over
to this beautiful looking mock-up that
we have over here after we're done with
the CSS for all of our pages we're then
going to jump into JavaScript which will
allow us to make our store page
interactive this will make us that the
add Cart button actually adds elements
to the cart down here through a move
element actually removes them and
changing the numbers inside of the
quantity will actually update the total
and that is all there is to HTML while
we have covered many HTML elements there
are still many more HTML elements that
we have not covered
I have only selected the most important
and useful HTML elements to cover in
this introductory course because many of
the HTML elements are either obsolete or
only useful in very specific scenarios
we're going to be taking the band
webpages that we created and style the
about page to look exactly as this image
on the right here to give you an idea of
what we're starting with over here is
going to be our an about page that we
have currently designed with just the
HTML and no CSS also as a side note
before watching this video if you know
nothing about CSS make sure you wash my
learn CSS and 20 minutes video in order
to get primed on what you'll need to
know in order to watch this video and
follow along now let's get started into
the CSS design for this page the first
thing I want to note is that I've added
a fonts folder into our project and
included the two fonts that we're going
to be using to style some of our
elements I also in our images folder
changed our bandmembers PNG to be a
square image so that it'll fit perfectly
inside of a circle and I changed our
footer images the Facebook logo Spotify
a logo and YouTube logo to be white
instead of black so they're going to
show up on top of our light blue
background that our footer will have now
that we have that another way let's
create our CSS file that we're going to
be writing all of our code in we're just
going to call this Styles dot CSS then
instead of our about HTML page in the
head let's add in a link give it a row
of stylesheet and an href of style.css
now if we say that nothing over here
will change because we don't actually
have anything loaded into our Styles dot
CSS but to test this let's just give our
HTML a background color and we'll make
it red we saved that perfect our
background changes to red which means
that everything in our Styles dot CSS is
being loaded in dart about HTML page now
it's clear that a little way and get
started the first thing that we're going
to want to do is we're going to want to
style the header portion of our site if
we go into our body HTML page here we
see that our header we have our
navigation which is these three boats
the top here as well as our
header for the generics which is our
band name the very first thing that
we're going to do is give our header
element a background image that is equal
to the background image that you see
over here in order to do that let's
first give our header class and we'll
just call it main header and our styles
at CSS we'll use a selector to select
that class and then use the background
image property to set an image for our
background now this background image
property works very similar to the H ref
for an anchor tag we'll use URL and then
inside of the URL we will specify where
our image comes from in our case the
image comes from our images folder over
here this header background jpg so we'll
just put instead of here
images slash header background jpg if we
save that and go back to here we'll see
that our image is going to be behind
here right now this doesn't quite look
right though in order to fix that we're
going to use the background size
property and set this to cover well this
is going to do is it's going to tell the
background to expand as much as it can
until one of the borders is at the very
edge of either the width or the height
so it expand either as wide as it can or
as tall as it can until it can't get any
larger without surpassing the size of
the image so if we say that you see that
our image has expanded all the way as
wide as it can and as tall as it can and
the last edge to hit is the width this
is the full width of our image and it
cut off the top and the bottom of our
image that's exactly what we want our
image to do this means that if we resize
our page our image will grow and shrink
as needed without us having it edit or
any extra code as you can see in our
example photo the background image has a
slightly darker hue to it than over here
so in order to do that we're going to
add a second background this time we're
going to use a background color and
we're going to set it to RGB a and we'll
just use black with a 60% transparent
now if we save that you'll see that
nothing actually changed about our
background this is because by default
you can only use either a background
color or a background image can you get
around this we're going to use what's
called background blend mode this is
essentially telling the browser how do
you want to blend these two different
backgrounds together and we're going to
use multiply which is essentially just
going to combine these two together over
top of each other and as you can see on
the right we now have a grayish dark
color to our background instead of it
just being entirely opaque now all we
need to do is add a little bit of
padding underneath of this lettering
down here so that we match the spacing
we have over here and to do that we can
just use padding bottom and we'll set it
to something like 30 pixels if we say
that we now have a nice gap on the
bottom here you may also notice that
around our background image we have some
white space in between here even though
in our about HTML this is the very first
thing in our body this is because CSS
styles are being defaulted onto certain
elements such as the HTML element and
body element if we go into our
stylesheet and at the very top here just
put HTML and body is our two selectors
and we set the margin to zero and the
padding to zero we say that will see
that now those margins and padding to go
away on the side here but we still have
a margin on the top this is because our
UL element also has a default margin on
the top so if we go in set our UI
element to have a margin of zero as well
and save that you now see that our
background takes the entire width and
goes all the way to the very top of our
page generally though you don't want a
style using elements such as getting rid
of the margin on all you ELLs so when I
are about here we're going to give our
nav a class of nav to indicate that this
is our navigation and here we use the
nav class that we just created followed
by ul to say that all the us inside of
the nav will now have no margin if we
say that this will look exactly as
before but now
all of our normal us will still have a
margin but the Ewell's inside of a
navigation class will not have a margin
now before we get started on styling the
nav we're gonna want to use the
everything selector to set a few
generals styles that will apply to all
the elements in our HTML the first one
that we're gonna want to use is box
sizing we're going to want to set this
to border box what this does is it makes
us so that the size of our elements are
determined by the padding and the margin
as well as the actual size of the
content so if we had a box and we set
the width to be 200 pixels and we set
the padding to be 20 pixels without
border box the width of that object
would be 200 pixels wide plus 20 pixels
on the right for padding and 20 pixels
on the left for padding making it 240
pixels wide with border box though the
width attribute takes into account the
padding as well so if we set a width of
200 pixels our element will be exactly
200 pixels wide and the padding will be
on the inside of those pixels if that
doesn't make any sense we'll be able to
see more examples of this as we continue
on style in this page another attribute
that we want to apply to all of our
elements is going to be our font family
this would be the default font family
that where all of our text is going to
use in our case we're going to use the
railway font but since this font is not
a generic font that can be used on
websites we need to import this font in
order to do that we're going to use
google fonts and import it using this
URL this URL can be found on the google
fonts web page and you can search for
any font on there that you want and then
all you have to do is click on that font
click the import and it'll give you this
link to copy and paste into your CSS now
if we save this you'll see all of our
font will change to railway the last
thing that I want to apply to all of our
elements is a default text color in
general black on white is very high
contrast and can be tiresome on your
eyes to read so I like to use a more
subtle text color of 777 here which is
just going to be a light gray which is
much easier the eyes to read now that we
have that out of the way let's style a
navigation element
first let's go to our about HTML and
remove this HR tag this HR tag was only
there to add an underline for our
navigation but we'll do that in CSS as
boarders are much easier represented in
CSS I also want to give our navigation
another class of main nav this is
because we will have multiple different
types of navigations that we want to
style similarly but we only have one
main navigation that's going to be at
the top of our page so now if we go back
to our Styles dot CSS what style our
actual math class first we've already
admitted so the margin is zero so that
our nav will no longer have any margins
around it but we want to maybe make our
elements though they're in line with
each other as opposed to on separate
lines as they are on here so do this
will select the nav element and then we
will select the li element under that
nav and we will give them a display of
inline this tells us that the browser
should render all these elements in line
with each other as opposed to on
separate outlines which is the default
for a list next we want to style the
actual links themselves that are in our
navigation element to do this we want to
give them some padding so let's say
we'll use a padding of 0.5 e/m which
will just space out these elements a
little bit from each other we also want
to give them the white text color to
match our mock-up that we have of our
image and then lastly we want to set it
to text-decoration:none which will
remove that underline from underneath of
our elements over here and if we save
that we see that our L text decoration
has removed the underline from these
elements change the color to white but
our padding has only added padding to
the left and right and not the top and
bottom as padding should do when you
give it just one number this is because
these are inline elements and inline
elements cannot apply padding on the top
or bottom what we need to do is we need
to change the display to the inline
block inline block is very similar to
inline except for it allows you to do
certain things such as add padding and
height to element that inline elements
do not allow you to do
so now as you see we have padding on the
top bottom left and right of all these
elements due to the theme in line block
the last thing we want to do is we want
to make it so that it is easy to tell
which element we were hovering over to
give the user some feedback to do this
will style the a tag again and we'll use
the hover selector to say when we hover
over the element we want to do something
and all we want to do is change the
background color and we'll just use a
light grayish color here so we use white
what we'll use transparency of 30% so
the white will show mostly is gray and
as you can see when we hover over these
elements we are now getting a background
color that tells us hey this is being
hovered this is all the styles that we
want to apply to our general navigation
now now we want to move on to our main
nav across because this is going to be
styles that are applied to only the main
navigation and not all of our other
navigations the first thing that we want
to do is we want to make us to the text
will be in the center of our screen
since our navigation should be centered
at the very top of the screen we also
want to make us the font size a little
bit bigger so it is easier to read we'll
just use one point one en which will
make it about 10% bigger and then we'll
change the font weight to be lighter as
opposed to the stronger font weight so
that way it blends a little bit better
into the background and then lastly we
want to add a border bottom to our
element to replace that HR that we
deleted and it'll be one pixel wide
completely solid and we'll just use
another light gray color here
and if we save that we now see that we
have a border on the bottom and our
element the very top the last thing that
we need to do is space out our elements
from each other because right now
they're very close to each other to do
this we'll use the main nav again and
we'll select the li elements and we'll
just give them a little bit of padding
so we'll say padding of zero on the top
and bottom and 5% on the left and right
there we go now our elements are spaced
out from each other and as our screen
grows the elements stay spaced out from
each other and as it shrinks they stay
spaced out again the last thing we have
to style on our header is going to be
the actual name of the band here if we
go back to our mock-up over here you see
that this is going to be much larger and
it is a completely different font then
we have already here by the default so
to do this let's go back to our about
page and let's add a class here and
we'll just call it band name we're also
at a second class of band name large
because we have two instances where our
band name will be rendered once in the
header where it is very large and a
second time in the footer of where it is
a more normal size this is why we are
going to use this band name class to
style all of the elements that we need
to make the band name look good and then
this band name large class to make the
band name in the header of larger let's
first start with the just normal band
name class in this class we're going to
first want to make the text-align:center
this will cause it to appear in the
center of the screen and then we want to
remove all margins from this element
because h1 elements by default have
margin we say that it'll get squished a
little bit closer together and then we
want to increase the font size I sense
this is just going to be our normal band
name and not the large one we're just
going to use this font size of 40 m and
save that then we want to change the
font family
this font family is going to be booter
0-0 but if we save that you'll see on my
local machine this updates to be the
correct font that's because I have
booters zero zero installed on my
computer normally this will not be the
case especially when you upload your
website to be hosted somewhere else in
order to load this style in we first
want to grab our font files here and we
want to import them using the app font
face property in here we want to use the
font family this essentially tells our
browser what name do we want to use for
this font we are going to use booter
zero zero this is the name that you will
set when you set the font family down
here then we need the source this
essentially tells the browser where is
this font coming from this is just like
the background image URL so we're going
to use fonts slash from booters zero
zero and we'll use the first one here
the WOFF and tell it that this format is
WOFF then we want to import our other
source which is URL fonts through to
zero zero whap - let me get rid of these
back slashes here and we'll use the
format of wofe - this tells the browser
that we have these two different types
of fonts here the buddha 0 0 woth and
buddha 0 0 woof - and it tells that
which format is each one the reason we
have multiple sources is because some
browsers don't support all types of
sources such as woth - or just the
normal woof this is so now with having
multiple sources here the browser will
take the very first source and if that
one works it'll use it and then if that
one's not acceptable it'll go down to
the second source here lastly we want to
put a font weight which tells us what
weight is this font
just normal and same with clown style
this is just a normal font not italics
or anything so we'll put normal here now
we have that font loaded into our page
so we have glitter zero zero that is
normal and normal style but over here
you see that our font is bolded and
doesn't quite look the same as our
mock-up this is because h1 tags by
default bold their font to get around
this we're going to set the font weight
to be normal if we say that our font now
looks exactly as it does over here the
last thing we need to do is set the
color of the font to be white and if we
save that this now looks almost exactly
the same as our mock-up does over here
and that's everything that we need to do
except for this font is a little bit too
small this is why we use that and name
large class inside of the band name
large class we're going to set the font
size we're going to make it 9:00 a.m. if
we save that that is now going to be
much larger and it is going to look
almost identical to how large it is over
here and if you want you can play around
with this number make it 8:00 a.m. for
example and save it and it'll look great
either way now that we have the header
completely styled let's move on to style
in the section content of our web page
over in the about HTML page let's add a
class to our section we're just going to
call this content section
essentially clarifying that this section
is just for content and we can reuse
this on all of our other content
sections across our index and our store
page I also want to give it a classic
container which we will use to specify a
maximum size as well as some padding on
the outsides of our text so that way
it's not quite squished up all the way
against the edge of the screen back and
styles dot CSS let's use the dot content
section class that we just created and
give it a margin of 1 a.m. this will
give us a little bit of spacing on the
top left right and bottom of our element
so that way it distinguishes itself from
the previous element
then we use our dark container class
that we just created and in here we'll
style a max width which says that the
max width of our element is going to be
900 pixels wide this means if our
element tries to get any larger than 900
pixels it'll just stay at 900 pixels if
I save that and increase my screen size
you can see that this element stops at
900 pixels but I just thought it was
showing up on the left side instead of
centered to Center it we're going to set
the margin on top and bottom to 0 and
then we are going to use Auto as the
left and right margin this tells it that
the margins on the left and right will
be as large as they need to be and be
exactly the same so that way the text
will be always in the center and if we
bring this all the way over to the side
you'll see that we have a large margin
on the right and left which centers our
text on the middle and then lastly we
just want to add a little bit of padding
back to this container to push it away
from the sides so we'll use 0 on the top
and bottom and 1.5 VM on the left and
right in order to give us a little space
so that our text does not run right up
against the edge of our webpage next we
need to style the actual heading for
this element we can use another class on
our h2 here and we'll just call it
section header there we go
this is because all of our sections are
going to be styled with the same exact
header so we'll use this class again on
our home page and our about page now in
our Styles dot CSS let's grab that
section header class and in here we're
going to just use a font family and this
font family is called metal mania which
again is not on the computer by default
so we have to use another import URL
from google fonts and this import URL
like I said before you can find by going
onto the google fonts web page and
searching your font this is what the URL
is going to be for the metal mania font
and if we say that you see that our text
changes
you can also see that we have the same
problem where text is bolded as it was
over here in the generics so we'll just
change the font weight to be normal and
now if we say that you'll see that our
text is no longer bolded but it still
doesn't look exactly as we want it to
and this is because we need to change
the color on this to be able slightly
darker we'll use just three three three
wishes about halfway between our light
gray and completely black and then we
want to Center this text in the middle
of our screen text-align:center if we
save that you'll see that our section
header is now in the middle of our
screen to the right color but it's
slightly too small and we'll use the
font size property 2.5 E and to make
about two and a half times bigger save
that and there we go our heading is
perfect now the next element we need to
take care of is the image in our About
section as you can see on here the image
is the circle and it's displayed towards
the top of our text and the text just
flows perfectly around the image no
matter how large or small the image is
in order to do this let's first add a
class to our image and we'll just call
it our about and image because this is a
class we're only going to be using for
our about band and then here select that
about band image and now in order to
make it so that our text flows around
this image what we want to do is we want
to use the float property and tell it to
float left this means that the image
will remove itself from the flow and
float completely to the left side of the
document also as you can see our image
is quite large here so let's give it a
height of 200 pixels and a width as well
of 200 pixels
and if we say that you see that our text
is flowing perfectly around this but we
want it to flow from the top so in our
about here let's move our image above
our P tags and save it and now as you
can see from the very start of our text
it is flowing
on the image but our text is right up
against our image and we don't want this
in order to fix this let's give our
image 15 pixels of margin on all sides
in order to push the text away from the
image lastly in order to create a circle
we're going to use the border radius
property this property tells us how far
we want to curve the edges of our border
and in our case 50% will make a perfect
circle since we curve from 50% all the
way to the next 50% so if we save that
we have a perfect circle with our text
flowing around it as we expected if we
go over here as you can see it doesn't
quite look exactly the same because our
image is not at the very center of our
text it's at the very top but it's much
easier to style from the very top of the
text and I personally think it even
looks better this way as for the actual
text of our content we don't need to
change anything
because in our generic everything
selector we already set the font family
and color to be exactly the same as what
is over here so the last thing we have
left to do is address the footer which
we want to use a light blue background
around with our band name on the left as
well as our three elements on the right
for our buttons to go to YouTube Spotify
and Facebook in order to do this we're
going to need to supply some classes to
the footer we're going to use the class
of main footer similar to how we used
main header to specify that this is the
main footer on our web page then we are
going to use the band name class and
apply that to our band name and if we
say that go back here you'll see that
our band name has already updated to be
white text and the correct font and font
color and font size just because we
already created that band name style
before which is the power of using
classes since they're so reusable to
create many different elements and just
copy and paste them along your page as
you see fit so now let's go back to our
Styles dot CSS and style that main
footer element
our main fighter is overall very simple
all we had to do is edit background
color that's going to be that white blue
color here which I just copied over then
we're going to make all the text in this
main footer white so we're going to use
a color of white and then lastly we want
to have a little bit of padding between
our elements and the edge of the
background so we'll use a padding of
0.25 e/m on the top and bottom and then
0 on the left and right and if we save
that scroll down you see that we now
have that light blue background as well
as all of our text is white but we have
the problem of our footer being stacked
vertically when we want it to be stacked
horizontally in order to fix this
problem we're going to go back to our
about HTML and we're going to use a
second div element in here with the
class of container and main footer
container that will wrap all the content
inside of our footer there we go
and now in our Styles dot CSS we'll make
the main footer container the purpose of
this main footer container is to wrap
our elements in and display flex element
a flex display order also known as flex
box is a very complex layout element
that you can use it as CSS but we're
only going to skim over the top of it
because in this video we don't have the
time to cover the full complexities of
flexbox but in the future I will make a
video covering flexbox in depth if we
scroll down here we see that already our
elements have lined up next to each
other on the left and the right which is
great but we want our right side element
to take up as much space as possible
while our left side element should be as
small as possible in order to do this
we'll make it so that main footer
container the ulo
inside of it which is our navigation on
the right here we want it to grow to
take up as much space as possible so
we'll use flex grow and give it a value
of 1
- tell it to grow then we also want to
align our text in that element to the
end of the elements we'll use text line
and to tell our text to be on the right
side instead of left side we also want
it so that our YouTube Spotify and
Facebook links will be centered with
this band log on the left here to do
this we'll use the align items property
instead of test center - say - Center
everything vertically inside of this
flex box next all we need to do is style
our navigation which we've already
created a class for so on our UL we'll
add a class of nav as well as footer nav
so that we can use specific stylings for
a footer and save that as you can see it
has already changed but we have the
background hover and the elements have
lost their period on the left side
denoting that it's a list item now all
we need to do in here is change our
footer nav Li so that we have a
different set of padding around these
elements will use a padding of zero on
the top and bottom and 0.5 eeehm on the
left and right to give these elements a
little bit of space around each other
next we're going to make it so the
images are going to be quite a bit
smaller than they are right now
since they're a bit oversized so we'll
use the footer nav select all the images
give them a width of 30 pixels and a
height of 30 pixels if we save that we
see that now everything is Center
aligned together inside of the footer
our images are smaller they have the
hover element which is the same from
this navigation up here and they also
allow us to click them and go to their
links the great thing about this webpage
is that it's also responsive on
different sizes so if we increase the
size of our page you see that everything
flows great around each other without
breaking everything's working everything
looks great whether it's full size or
small it doesn't matter it'll work
flawlessly this web page is though not
designed specifically with mobile sizing
in mind so it doesn't look as good on a
small screen size as it does on a
slightly larger screen size
but either way it looks great no matter
which size the browser is at and that is
all there is to creating the about
fanpage for this website we have all the
stylings so that our page looks almost
exactly the same as the mock-up that we
had before and it is even scalable to
different browser sizes and it looks
good on all those different sizes the
best part about this is since that we
used very generic named classes such as
container band name and nav were able to
apply these classes to the rest of our
pages such as the home page here and the
store page here in order to get a head
start without having to restyle the
elements such as this navigation and the
footer every single time if you guys
want to follow along with this project
and use the exact same code that I have
to style this about page here all this
code is going to be available on my
github which will be linked in the
description below from there you can get
these font files that I'm using as well
as the different logos and background
images that I'm using and even the
actual code for this video is available
on my github
we're going to tackle styling the
homepage of our website to look exactly
as this image on the right here in order
to get started with this let's open up
our index.html page with live server and
here we have all the HTML with no CSS
styling is applied to it the first thing
that we want to do is to go into our
about HTML copy our link tag from the
head and paste this into our index.html
file this way we'll be able to load
those files in from our Styles dot CSS
file into our home page here as you can
see this already has made some changes
by changing our font font color and etc
based on our everything selector the
next thing that we need to do is apply
our Styles to our header that we created
in the last episode such as the class of
main header if we save this we'll see
that on the right our header will update
and then we have our navigation which we
can apply the classes of nav and main
nav to and there we go we'll get rid of
this HR here as well as these two line
breaks and our comments as these are no
longer needed since we have a background
image and these line breaks will be
taken care of using CSS but to save that
and then add our final class here for
the band name and band name large and if
we save that our header now looks very
similar to how our about page header
looks but we have these two buttons down
here that we need to style still the
first thing we want to do is create a
button class for all of our buttons will
do this in a similar way that we styled
our navigation elements by having a nav
class and then another class to style
what type of Navitus but first we'll
just create this generic button class
that all of our buttons will be able to
use inside of our Styles dot CSS let's
add the selector for that button class
and start applying the different styles
we need we know that we want all of our
buttons text to be centered in the
middle and center of our button so we'll
use text-align:center to put our text in
the center horizontally and then we'll
be using vertical line of middle to put
our text in the middle for
to clean if we save that we'll notice
that no changes were made over here
because our buttons aren't tall enough
or wide enough for our text to need to
be aligned in the middle yet but as we
start adding different padding's and
different heights and widths will see
that our text will always be in the
center next let's add a little bit of
padding around our button so that we
have more space between the text in the
edge of our button to do this we'll use
padding and then we'll give it point 6 7
p.m. of padding on both the top bottom
left and right by just doing one number
and if we save that plus there buttons
have gotten slightly larger last thing
we want to do is when we hover over a
button we want our cursor to change to a
pointer icon as opposed to the normal
arrow icon so we're going to go into
here change our cursor to pointer and
save that and now when we hover over our
buttons we'll get the pointer icon
instead of the typical arrow icon the
next thing we want to do is apply our
button specific classes for a header and
we'll just call this button header now
if we go into our Styles CSS use the
selector for our button header class we
can start adding styles that are
specific for this gate or latest album
button the first thing we want to do is
use the margins around our button to be
able to position it whatever you want if
we look at our image here we can see
that our button is positioned so it is
slightly offset from the center and
offset from the left edge of the screen
we're going to be using margins with
percentages and EMS in order to
accomplish this
so if we use margin the first value if
we use all four values the margin
corresponds to the top margin which we
want to set to 0.5 eeehm which will be
half the size of the font we then want
to use 15% to correspond to our right
side margin which will take up 15% of
the total space our object can occupy
then we can use to e/m as the bottom
margin and another 15% as the left side
margin if we save this we see that our
object already aligns itself slightly
offset from the left and not quite
centered in our space this is exactly
what we want next we want to style the
button to look like it does on this page
the first thing that we're going to want
to do change
text color to be white and then we want
to add a border around our object it's
going to be two pixels solid and we're
going to use this color which is a
slightly bluish color as our border
color now if we save that and go back we
already see that our text colors changed
to white and we have blue border around
the object but we still have this gray
background in order to get rid of that
we just set the background color and
we're going to use a very very opaque
white color which would be RGB a 255 255
and point 1 if we save that we now get a
button that looks very similar to this
button in color but spacing it's still
not quite right what we need to do is
set the border radius of our object to
be zero which move completely remove the
rounded corners of our object so that we
now have a perfectly square corner
object over here just like in this image
the border radius corresponds to how
rounded the corners are so by setting to
zero we have no rounded edges to our
corner next we want to increase the font
size we're just going to set that to 1.5
VM to be about 50% larger and then we
want to make the font weight to be
lighter so the text is slightly thinner
and if we save that our button is
looking very similar to our button over
here but you'll notice that we don't
quite have the same hat email on the
left and right in order to fix this
we'll set our padding on the left to be
two e/m and our padding on the right to
also be 2 a.m. now if we say that our
button looks almost exactly the same as
our button in here this is perfect but
when we hover over this button nothing
actually happens we have no way to know
we're actually hovering over it in order
to fix that we use the button header
hover selector here and we'll set the
background color and we'll just make it
a slightly less opaque version of the
color that it already is which is white
but we'll use 0.3 instead of 0.1 as our
pasady so now if we hover over it you
see that our button gets slightly
lighter so that way we know that we're
actually
overtop of it one thing that you may
notice is if we zoom out here on our
image and we increase our font our
window size to be even larger our button
will become very offset to the left and
not as centers as we like it to be in
order to fix this in our index.html page
let's wrap this button here inside of a
div with the class of container if we do
this we've already created this
container class which has a limited with
this means the padding of our button on
the left and right will be inside of
that confined with space of the
container so if we save this and
increase our size of our browser to be
even larger you see that our button will
always stay similar to the center of the
screen because it's inside of a
container with a limited width that's
exactly what we won our thing our
webpage to react as now let's zoom that
back in so it's easier for you guys to
see there we go and now it's work on
styling this button right here for the
play button will use very similar styles
to our header button but we'll also add
a play button class to this if we say
that we already see that this is very
similar to our style over here what we
want to do is we want to make this
button entirely round and we want to
make the icon on the inside blue as
opposed to white in order to do this
we'll go to our Styles dot CSS here and
we'll use our button play class to style
our play button how we want the first
thing we want to do is send our button
horizontally in the screen so we're
going to use margin with zero on the top
and bottom and auto on the left and
right in order at our button to Center
itself in the screen but as you'll
notice our button actually just centers
over onto the left side this is because
buttons are not block level element and
only block elements can have an auto
margin to get around this will change
our button to be disloyal ock now if we
save that will notice our button is
perfectly centered in our screen the
next thing we want to do is change the
color of this icon to be our blue color
here which we can just copy from our
border
save that and now we have that same blue
color instead of our button we want to
increase the font size in order to make
the icon larger we'll use 4 a.m. and
then we want to change our border radius
to be 50% in order to make a perfect
circle and there we go but you'll notice
that our button is more of an oval than
a circle and that's because our button
has different padding on it so we need
to completely remove padding from our
button in order to make it a perfect
circle but you'll see there's a slight
problem where a button gets really
scrunched up so we want to give our
button a width and a height and weird
even make these exactly the same so our
button is a perfect circle as opposed to
an oval we'll just use 100 pixels and if
we save that you see that we now have a
perfect circle button in the center of
our screen that is slightly offset from
our button up here very similarly to
over here and if we increase the size of
our screen you see that our buttons will
stay positioned how we want them no
matter what size our screen is that's
exactly what you want and everything
that we need to do in order to make the
header of our page look exactly the same
as this image over here the next thing
that we need to do is work on this
section of our page which contains our
tour dates and is the main content of
this homepage the first thing we can do
is use our styles that we created in our
previous video we can use our class over
here of content section in order to
specify that this is a Content section
and we can also use the class container
in order to specify that we don't want
the width to grow over a certain size
next we can use the class here of
section header just as we created in our
other video that will mark this header
as a section header and Center and give
it the right font that we want now we
need to tackle the individual rows of
our tour date the first thing we can do
is remove the HR as well as these less
than and greater than symbols since
these were only there in order to be
used for spacing in our HTML and we will
do all that with CSS now instead so now
if we save that we see that our row is
completely scrunched together which is
perfect for us to start styling
we also want to give our rope a class of
two arrow so that we can say each row
will be styled in the same exact way
what's going to our styles dot CSS here
add that to array of selector and get
started styling it the main thing we
want our tour row to do is to give us
padding between our different rows as
well as give us a border on the bottom
of the row so to start let's use border
bottom to give a bottom border tomorrow
and we'll make it one pixel solid black
if we say that we see that we now have
that Porter on the bottom of our object
similar to how the HR worked but we also
want there to be a little space between
the row and the row below it as well as
between the row and the border in order
to give us space between the row and the
border will use padding since padding a
space between content and the border and
we'll set this to one ECAM if we save
that we now have space between our
content and our border and in order to
give a space between the content below
in our border we used margin which is on
the outside of our border and we'll set
that to the same one a.m. now if you say
that we have space in between all of our
rows here let's take this to our item or
to a row class and give it to all of the
different rows inside of our content
here we can just copy and paste that
into all these divs and after we're done
with that if we save it we'll see that
we now have borders on the bottom here
let's get rid of all these hrs so that
it's easier to see and you'll see now
that we have borders on the bottom of
all these different rows very similar to
over here but you'll notice there should
be no border on our last row here and
you may think Oh we'll just remove the
class and that will solve the problem
but I will get rid of all about padding
and margins in order to fix this problem
we can use what is called the last child
selector so if each to a row last child
this will select the last child with
this to a row class and if we just give
it a border bottom of none to say that
it should be no border and say that
you'll see the border on this last child
has been completely removed now we can
get started on styling the different
elements inside of our row let's first
start with the date element here
and we're gonna give this a class of two
or item which will give to all the items
in our row and we'll give it a specific
class of two or date and this will work
very similar to how we've done buttons
and nav so far let's first start by
styling the two ER item element in here
all we want to do is set very specific
padding margin spacings all that we want
between all of our two items so first we
want to add a padding right between all
of our elements to give them a little
bit of space of 0.5 p.m. if we save that
you'll see that now there's a little bit
of padding to the right side of our date
element here which is exactly what we
want but we also want these elements to
display in line with a specific width as
we know in line elements cannot have any
width applied to them for example if we
were to apply a width of a thousand
pixels here and save this our object
does not actually become a thousand
pixels wide and that's because it's an
inline element so what we want to do is
change the display to the inline block
which will make this act like an inline
element as then it won't break the line
when it's done but it'll also be able to
have widths and Heights applied to it
like a block element and if we save that
we see our element is now a thousand
pixels wide we don't actually want that
so we'll remove that line perfect the
only downside of inline block is it does
add a tiny bit of space between each
element that we cannot actually remove
but that is okay for now now let's use
that to our data class that we also
assigned it and start styling that as
well first we want to give it a slightly
darker color than the rest of our row to
match the styling in this page so we'll
give it a color of five five five which
is a slightly darker version of our 777
color and if we save that you'll see our
color is a little bit darker we also
want to make it that it's bold
so we use font weight of bold if you
saved that you notice not much extra
changes and that's because we used a
strong tank over here for our element
strong tags are meant only when you want
to emphasize something and in this case
our bolding is only for visual instead
of for emphasis so we want to change
this to a span tag
to remove the special emphasis applied
to it since it is only meant to be
visually bolded and not actually
emphasized for importance now if we save
that you'll see it'll look perfect let's
go back to our style best CSS and give
this a specific width and we'll just use
11% for our width here and save that and
now it gives us a little bit of extra
spacing and as we increase the size of
our browser the spacing will increase
with it perfect now let's move on to the
other elements of our tour item instead
of our index.html let's give all of our
elements the tour item class as well as
a specific class in this case this is
our city so we'll call it to our city
this next one is going to be our arena
so we'll give it to our item into our
arena and this last one is our button so
we'll give it the class of button will
also give it a tour item class and a
tour button class and say that now our
role looks a little bit better has a
little bit of space in between our
elements but everything's not quite
lined up probably want it so in our
styles that CSS here let's style our
individual tour elements starting with
the city element which we're just going
to give a width of 24% this is a
slightly larger text than our date is
let me save that and now it gives us a
little bit of spacing we'll go on to our
to our arena and we'll give this a width
of 42% since this is our largest element
by far and then lastly we use the tour
button and instead of giving this an
actual width because if we give it a
width for example of the 19% and we say
that as we increase our screen size will
see that our button will get wider which
we don't actually want to happen so
instead we'll use max width as opposed
to whit's which means our element will
never be larger than 19% of the screen
so now if we shrink this our button will
stay exactly the same no matter how
large or how small it goes because the
width will always be the same as the
content but it will never become larger
than 19% of the screen so if we make our
screen very small coz-theta our button
will break on a tumor
instead of shrinking even further that's
exactly what we want
he also may be wondering by looking at
these widths why they don't exactly add
up to a hundred percent because you
would think we want to fill up 100% of
the space and you are correct we do want
to fill up 100% of this space but as I
talked about inline-block elements add
some amount of spacing between each
other in line block element that we
cannot remove we have to account for
this by making our widths slightly less
than 100 percent when added together to
do this I subtracted about 1% from each
of these widths after making them total
up to 100% this way we have 96 percent
with taken care of so that way our
screen won't break onto multiple
different lines until it becomes very
very small and in that case you'll see
it does break onto multiple lines that
is okay because our size our screen is
not really meant to be viewed on mobile
this is mostly for desktop design let's
make that size a little bit larger here
there we go and let's copy these styles
onto all of our different elements over
here in all of our different rows I'll
do that really quick there we go as you
can see now all of our rows are styled
correctly but they all line up exactly
so the spacing is exactly what we want
it to look like and if we increase the
size of our browser everything stays in
line and all of our different columns
and scales to be responsive with the
size of our browser this is perfect the
only thing we have left to do is style
our buttons so that it look the same on
this page as they do on this page in
order to do that let's add one final
class to our buttons which will be
button primary since it'll be the
primary button of our site and this
primary attribute really refers mostly
to the coloring of our button since our
button base class already applies all
the styling for the different sizing
padding and margins that we need so now
if we go over to our Styles dot CSS add
this button primary class in here we can
now style the different colors we need
to let's first start by adding a color
of white which my car text Claire white
as well as our background color which we
want to say to this color and if we say
that we now see our buttons are the
exact same color as over here we next
want to remove all of the border from
this element so we don't have this great
border around here anymore
and then we want to make our border
radius to be slightly bent around the
corners as you can see over here we have
a slight bend in the corner so we'll
make our border radius the 0.3 éem and
if we save that you see that our button
is already looking great but our text is
a little bit dull in here so let's make
the font-weight:bold to make our text
pop a little bit and if we say that our
buttons now look perfect and they look
exactly the same as our buttons over
here the only thing we have left to do
is that a hover element to this so that
we can tell though we're hovering over
our element we'll do this exactly the
same way by using our button primary
with the hover selector and we'll just
give it a background color that is going
to be slightly darker so in here with a
background color and we'll just set that
to this color right here now if we hover
over a button you'll see that it'll get
darker to note that we are hovering over
this button and it is easier for our
users to know what's going on the last
thing we have left to do is style the
footer to be exactly the same as the
footer on our about page so in order to
do this we'll just go to our about page
go down to the footer and copy all the
footer elements heidi's classes all of
that and we'll paste it over our footer
here since we know that we want them to
be exactly the same
and now if we save that or scroll down
here our footer now looks exactly the
same as I've put it over here which is
exactly what we want now if we zoom out
our webpage here a little bit to be a
hundred percent increase the size you'll
see that our content stay is them side
of these bounds and that is due to the
container class that we added this is
perfect for making our site responsive
without stretching too far on larger
screens and also making it look decent
on smaller screens such as this or this
that's all there really is to creating a
CSS for this home page you'll notice
that this was much easier than doing our
about page and that is because all the
styles that we used in our
Paige we were able to copy over and use
in our home page
we're going to be taking the store page
that we've designed earlier with HTML
and style it to look exactly like this
image on the right here now let's get
started here by opening up our store
HTML page using live server to see what
we have to get started with there we go
and the first thing that we need to do
is copy over the style sheet that we've
already created and link it so we'll
just copy this link here from the index
page paste it into our store page so we
now have access to all the styles that
we've already written and as you can see
it's already taken effect the next thing
that we need to do is go onto our header
here and we need to style our header to
be exactly like our home page in our
about page as you can see here so to do
that let's just add the classes that
we've already created of me and header
and our nav gonna have the class of main
nav and then nav
and there we go that looks good to
remove this HR and then finally style
our band name here with band name and
band name large we save that and every
go we have the same header that we have
on all of other pages and luckily for us
this is the only thing we need to do in
our header here the next thing we could
do is move on to this section and work
on this music card section right here we
can get started here by styling our
section with the classes that we already
have such as container and content
section if we save that you'll see we
get a little bit of padding from doing
that and then we can also title our
header here by using the class of
section header which we've already
created and we say that we now see that
our header for our section is properly
styled and that we can move on to
styling the actual items that are going
to be going into our cart let's first
look at what we actually want the style
to look like over here in our image and
we can see that we have the title of the
item at the very top centered we have
the image here and then we have the
price and the button to add it to the
cart on the bottom that are slightly
inset from the sides of the album image
so we're going to do that let's first
add a class to this div that wraps all
of this content here and we're just
gonna call this shop item
and this is just going to represent a
single item that we had for sale in our
shop and this will be usable in the
music and the merch section the next
thing we can do is we can actually
remove the divs that wrap this album
since we can use CSS in order to make
album on its own line without having to
use a div to do that so let's remove
these divs here and then we can also
change the strong tag to a span since we
know that the we want this album one to
be bolded but we don't actually want to
put emphasis on it that the strong tag
does for things like screen readers we
just want to style that in CSS so let's
add a class to this here we're just
gonna call this shop item title since
this is going to be the title and the
name of our shop item that we have here
next we have our image which we are
going to add a class to as well we can
just call this shop item image so that
we can style our image to resize it as
we need and then lastly we have this
bottom div here which are the details of
our shop item so we're just going to
give this a class we'll call it shop
item details and inside of that we have
the price of the shop item here so we
can give that the class of shop item
price and then we have our button here
which we already have two classes for a
button and button primary since this
will be the bluish colored primary
button that we have and then we'll add
another class to it of a shop item
button so we can style this button
specifically for the shop item as needed
and if we save that go back to here
you'll see that some of the things in
our page have already changed we got the
blue button now and now if we can
actually go into our Styles - CSS and
start styling these elements the first
thing that we're gonna want to do is
we're going to want to give some margin
around our shop items so they don't run
up writing next to each other as you can
see that these two items are so if we go
in here we select our shop item we can
just give it a margin on all sides of 30
pixels if we say that you now see that
we have a spacing on the sides bottom
top of these shop items so they won't
run right up against each other
the next thing we can do is style this
shop item title right here do that we'll
just select the shop item title and
we'll get started styling it the first
thing we want to do is we want to make
it so that it is display:block so that
way it'll be on its own line as opposed
to being in front of the image if the
width of our browser is large enough the
next thing we're going to do is we want
to make this item 100% width so that
it'll take up the entire width of the
top of the image and that way when we do
text-align:center the text will actually
center itself above the image just like
that the next thing we can do is change
the actual size and color the font so if
we go in here we can make the
font-weight:bold so it is a little bit
larger we can make the font size the 1.5
e/m so it is also slightly bit bigger
and then lastly add a color that is
slightly darker than our current color
here we saved that you see that we now
have a great title but it's really close
to our image so we'll just add a margin
on the bottom here and we'll make that
about 15 pixels and we say that and now
we see it spaced out above our image
which is perfect this is exactly what we
want for our title the next thing that
we should tackle is the actual image of
our shop item right now this image is
quite large and takes up almost the
entire screen so what we want to do is
we just want to change that to the shop
item image is slightly smaller than it
is right now so we'll just give it a
height of 250 pixels did we say that
you'll see that our image shrinks down a
little bit and the width and the aspect
ratio stays the same because dive by
default the width will be automatically
as large as it needs to be for the image
to be the same aspect ratio when the
height is 250 pixels this is because we
didn't actually set it with so it
defaults to auto next we want to work on
this details row down here where we have
the price and the button for adding it
to our cart so what's going to here and
we'll do shop item details to select the
wrapper that goes around our details for
our price and our button here and we'll
make this display flex
there we go the reason we're using
display affects is because we want to
Center these items vertically so that
they are all within the same line as you
can see this price is at the top of the
line here we wanted to line up with the
text in our button so to do that we'll
use align items
Center in order to centrally aligned all
of the items inside of this container
and as you can see this looks perfect
over here the last thing we want to do
is add a little bit of padding 5 pixels
on the top bottom left and right so that
way it's slightly inset from the image
and doesn't quite touch the image on the
top next we can move on to style in the
actual price of our shop item so this
shop item price and this doesn't take
many styles all we want to do is make us
so that the button is shoved all the way
to the right side of the screen so we'll
set Flex grow to 1 so that our price
will take up as much width as possible
if we say that you see that it pushes
this Add to Cart button all the way to
the end of our container right here next
thing we want to do is change the color
to make it slightly darker and that's
really all there is to styling the
actual item of our shop but what we want
to do is we want to make us a shop items
will all flow around each other and as
you can see our shop item doesn't quite
fit within the space of the image it's
taken up way too much of the width of
the screen in order to fix this we can
go back to our HTML here and we can wrap
all of these shop items inside of a div
and we'll just give it a class of shop
items so if we go up here create a div
give it a class of shop items there we
go look at the end of this div at the
end of all of our shop items for the
music section right here and indent
everything so that it looks nice there
we go and now we can actually select
that shop items did that we created and
we can give it a display of flex and if
we say that you now see that
everything's all in one wine and it goes
all the way way past the edge of our
screen we do not want that we want these
items to actually wrap so we can use the
property flex wrap in order to bake
these elements wrap and we'll just set
it to wrap so that if it goes past the
edge of our screen though
Rapp down and as you can see now they
all fill up in one column instead of
wrapping all the way to the end of the
screen you'll also see by changing flex
our display to flex your fish off items
our image is the total width of our item
so that our Add to Cart button doesn't
get put all the way to end here in our
album one title is properly centered
above the image this is exactly one the
last thing we want to do is when our
screen is larger these items will be
right next to each other like this and
we want to make sure that they're spaced
between them in the middle left and
right so we'll use justify content space
around which we'll put an even amount of
space on the left and right of every
single element inside of our container
and if we save that we now see we have
spacing between these elements and on
the left and right of them that's
exactly what we want for these shop
items now all that's left to do is to
create all these different classes and
add them to all the different shop items
which I'll do real quick here
and there we go that's all the styles
that we need for our shop item so now as
you can see as we scroll down all of our
buttons and prices are styled correctly
everything is lined up properly and if
we increase the size of our screen
you'll see that our items will line up
next to each other which means that our
site is actually responsive to different
screen sizes this is because we use
display flex with the wrap property so
that if it became too large for a screen
it would just wrap to the next line and
if our screen was large enough to allow
multiple items they would all stay on
the same line this is perfect for our
situation since we didn't want our
albums to only take up one line or be
two on a line when our screen was very
small so now what we need to do is do
the same thing to our merged section
that we've done to this section here by
wrapping our container in a shop items
div and then adding all these different
classes down to these elements here I'll
do that real quick now and there we go
I've added all the different styles to
our merged section since it's pretty
much exactly the same as this music
section here and as you can see if we
increase our screen size be large enough
there we go our items will be
side-by-side and if the screen size is
not large enough they'll stack on top of
each other just like this and this is a
perfect example of our flexbox working
because as you can see these are
side-by-side but these are not because
this coffee image is actually wider than
these images up here so it needs a wider
screen size in order for them to stack
side-by-side like this now the last
thing that we have to tackle is the
actual cart down here which is going to
be the most complex part of this page so
stick with me the first thing we need to
do is go back into our HTML and style
the different HTML elements that we need
with classes so that we can styled it to
look exactly like the card down here so
first let's take the classes that we
know we already have for this section we
can do container that we can do content
section there we go we can also style
this header here with content our size
section header there we go and now let's
get into the actual rows and headers of
our cart right here we don't need these
less-than and greater-than signs anymore
since we're going to be putting the
spacing in using CSS and same with these
strong tags we can replace these with
spans so let's do that real quick there
we go and now let's start adding the
actual classes that we need the first
thing that we want to do is style the
wrapper that goes around each of our
rows and we're going to just give that a
class of cart row and then we want to do
classes for our different items so we
have our item column our price column on
our quantity column since we want all
these to line up and be the same width
we'll give this a class and we're gonna
give that
art item and we'll also give it a class
of cart header since this item is in the
header of our cart and then lastly we'll
use the cart column class which we're
going to give to all of our different
columns of our cart section so that way
we can do consistent style in between
all of our columns without having to
copy and paste at other places let's do
a similar thing for the price there
we're going to give it a class of cart
price class of cart header and a class
of cart column and then lastly same
thing for quantity give it a class cart
quantity cart header and cart column and
there we go that's everything we needed
to do in order to style the header row
of our cart let's start by styling that
in our style sheet right now the first
thing we want to do is style the actual
headers of our columns so to do this we
can use the class cart header to select
them and then set a font weight of bold
since these are going to be bolded we
can set a font size to be slightly
larger at 1.2 p.m. and then lastly we
want to make the color darker so we'll
just use this color that's slightly
darker and then we can move on to
styling the actual individual columns
themselves so let's choose the select
your cart column here and get started
styling that in here we can use a border
bottom we'll just use one pixel solid
black border in order to put a border on
the bottom here but we also need space
in between our elements because if we go
back here you'll notice that our borders
are all running right up against each
other and this image is even overlaying
over the top of our borders in order to
get around this we're going to use some
margins around our elements here first
let's use a margin on the right side in
order to space our columns away from
each other
and we're just going to use a margin of
1.5 am here we save that you'll see that
now there's a space in between our
different columns we're also going to
put a padding on the bottom so the
spacing between the column and the
actual underline so we use padding
bottom here of 10 pixels and then we'll
also put a margin on the top of our
columns in order to put a little bit of
space between the top of our column and
everything above it so in this case the
actual border of the element for this
column so we use margin top 10 pixels
here and perfect now we need to actually
add these classes to the rest of our
items inside of our columns to do this
let's go back to our store HTML and copy
over all these classes to these other
different elements here let's do this
for the first one we'll copy over this
class cart row put it onto this div here
we also have the cart item which is
going to include both the image here and
this t-shirt name so we need to wrap
this inside of a div with the class of
cart item so they say this is our item
column they're also given a cart column
class since it's going to be a column
inside of our section here at the end of
the div down at the bottom and now if we
save this you already see that we
started to getting borders on the bottom
which is perfect next we can move over
this cart price to be inside of this
span here since this is the price for
item so we'll get of a class of cart
price and another class of cart column
there we go we can also remove these
less than and greater than symbols here
again since they're just used for
spacing and then lastly we have our cart
quantity which includes the input and
button down here so we can do a similar
thing where we wrap them inside of a div
so if we paste this div here instead of
cart item we want cart quantity and then
inside of that div we just want the
input and the button and there we go now
we have everything we need but you'll
see that they're spaced out so that
they're all on the line of their own in
order to get around this we want to do
is we want to use flux box again in
order to align these items properly so
if we go back to our Styles SCSS let's
style that cart row and we use display
flex in order to get all these items
onto one line just I did that's perfect
we're now running into the problem
though we're all columns are different
widths as you can see this item column
here is not wide enough to support all
the stuff in it but
price column doesn't line up with the
actual price here and the quantity is
way off in order to fix this we'll use
these cart item class the cart price
class and a cart quantity class that we
have five to our different columns in
order to style the widths of these
columns so they're all exactly the same
for our item let's use a width of 45%
there you go for the price we're going
to use a width of 20% and lastly for the
quantity will use a width of 35% if you
save that you'll see that now everything
lines up inside of the columns that they
should be inside of you'll also notice
that if you add these numbers up they
equal 100% but if you remember from our
first video when we are styling actually
our second video I'm sorry when were
styling the home page you'll notice that
we had to not quite equal 100% when we
were creating our widths this is because
we are using inline block elements to
style those an inline block elements
have spacing around them here we're
using flexbox to align our items so we
can actually use widths that add up to
exactly 100 percent because flexbox does
not any spaces in between the items
inside of its container this is why I
almost always use flexbox when laying
out element as opposed to inline block
flex box is also a great aligning
content inside of its box to be centered
horizontally or vertically which is a
problem you'll notice on the right here
where our content should be centered
horizontally or vertically I'm sorry in
order to look like this so that all of
our text is right in the center here but
over here our text is either at the
bottom over here or the top over here so
to fix that we'll go back to our cart
column here since if you remember all of
our content for each of these columns
has this cart column class around it and
we'll make this display of flex and then
we'll use a line items singer in order
to send our items along the vertical
right here we save that you'll see that
now all of our items are vertically
aligned exactly as they should be and
this is looking really close to what we
have over here - all the coloring that
we need to do for our different elements
in order to specifically select the
different elements we want to style
let's go back into our HTML here and add
some classes to our different elements
the first element that won't want to
style here is the span tag with the
title of the element so we'll do here is
we'll add a class we'll get it a title
or the name of cart item title specify
this as a title of our cart item we also
want to add a class here to our image so
we'll just use cart item image specify
this is the image of our cart item our
cart price is already styled which is
perfect and then we just need to add
styles to our input and our button here
so let's do class here we'll just give
it cart quantity input in order to
specify this is the input for our cart
quantity and then our button will have
the class a button which we've already
defined button danger which will specify
a red colored button and then also cart
quantity button in order to specify this
is the button for our cart quantity if
we say that you'll notice nothing over
here changes other than the button
styles are applied to this button so
then we can go into our styles does CSS
and actually start selecting and styling
these elements so let's go down here and
first let's style the actual title the
t-shirt title here by using cart item
title selector and then inside of this
title selector will put the color to be
a slightly darker color we'll give it a
little bit of margin on the left side so
that it's not quite right up against our
image here as you see so we'll just use
point five en for this and then lastly
we'll increase the font size slightly to
1.2 en if you say that you'll now see
that our image is slightly pushed away
from our item name which is exactly what
we want next thing we can style is the
actual image since our image is a little
bit too large right here so we can go in
here carte items image will change the
width to be 75 pixels so this image is
smaller if we save that you see our
image is now smaller but the height is
too tall so we're going to give it a
height of auto so the height will
automatically adjust to the width have
we saved that it's now within perfect
Oxbow
aspect ratio that it was
four and lastly we'll just add a slight
rounding of the corners here so we're
just going to use border-radius
and we'll just say for example ten
pixels if we save that and now rounds
the borders just a little bit which adds
a little bit of extra aesthetic to the
image I think the next thing we want to
target is this price over here and we
already have a cart price selector so
let's just do it inside of that will
increase the font size slightly to be
1.2 e/m and we'll make the color
slightly darker and if we save that
we'll see that the price now looks good
and we really don't have to do anything
to that the last two elements throw our
input and our button are going to take a
little bit more work let's go down here
and we can select that button danger
class that we added earlier to apply
this reddish colored button and we can
start adding our classes to this the
first thing that we want to do just
change the color of the text to be white
and we want to give it a background
color here that is going to be a reddish
color I just paste that in here that'll
be a red color and if we save that well
so that we not have this reddish button
we want to remove the border from the
button give it a slight border radius so
that has rounded corners and then lastly
increases so that it is a bold font here
if we say that we now have a
good-looking button but we have no hover
that happens when we go over the button
so let's add our hover effect using the
hover selector here and we can just give
it another background color that is
going to be slightly darker here and if
we save that and we hover we now get a
slightly darker red color when we hover
over the button which is perfect the
next thing we can select is our cart
quantity input which is going to take
quite a few styles applied to it in
order to give it a blueish border and a
smaller size the first thing we want to
do for this is to make it the same
height as our button over here so to do
that we'll use a height of 34 pixels say
that and we'll see that our input is now
the same height as our button
we also want to change the width of this
input to be quite a bit smaller so we
use a width of 50 pixels which should be
enough space in order to put our text
and have these buttons for incrementing
and decrementing the number inside of
here the next thing we want to do is you
want to give it a border radius so it
has slightly rounded corners we'll get a
border radius of 5 pixels will give it
also a border that's going to be one
pixel it's gonna be solid colored and we
want it to be the same exact color as
our buttons up here so we'll just copy
that back on color from our button and
we'll paste that in here now and we say
that you'll see that we now have the
border around our element which is great
we need to give it a slightly darker
colored background which is just
slightly darker than white and if we say
that you can see that we want to change
our text color to be slightly darker and
then we want to make sure we have no
padding around this element at all and
if we say that our input element is
starting to come both together we just
want to move our text to the center and
make it slightly bigger kick
so we'll do text align Center in order
to send our line our text we use a font
size here of 1.2 e/m to make our font
slightly larger and then lastly let's
use some margin on the right here 25
pixels in order to separate our input
from our button and if you save that you
see that now
this looks a lot like our mock-up over
here for our button and input and that's
pretty much all we need to do in order
to style our robe properly now I'm going
to copy these styles from this row onto
the second row and see what we have from
there
there we go that's all the styles that
I'm going to need in order to make this
we can also remove the HR down here at
the bottom and we can also remove this
cart quantity button class since we
never actually ended up using that class
so let's remove that from both of our
buttons here
and save that and you'll notice that
everything still looks exactly the same
you will notice however though that are
underlined borders here don't quite look
the same as over here as you can see we
have a solid border on the bottom for
our last row and over here we have a
separated border on the bottom in order
to do this we can use the last child
selector in our CSS in order to change
the border for the last child but the
child element selector only works for
the last child inside of a container and
right now these cart rows are not the
last child of the container that they're
inside as you can see this div right
here's the last child so let's wrap the
rows of our cart here inside of the
container now we'll just give this
container here a class of cart items
move this div down to the bottom here
now we can indent all this so it looks
pretty save it and you'll notice nothing
over here actually changes which is
perfect but now when we select a last
child of the cart row it'll be this cart
rail right here since it's the last
child of this carte items container so
now let's do that inside of our Styles
dot CSS here first thing that we're
going to do is select the cart row slash
child of it and in here we're going to
use that order bottom property in order
to set a one pixel solid black border
that is going to go across the entire
row here if we say that you'll see that
we now have one solid border on the
bottom but we still have our individual
borders that we want to remove to do
that we'll again select the cart row
last child
but we'll also select the cart columns
that are children of that actual cart
row and we'll remove the border from
them and if we say that you'll see that
now we have removed these individual
borders
and all we have is this solid line de
Borda right here on the bottom and that
looks exactly the same as over here
which is perfect now all we need to do
is title type style this total section
and this purchase button and we'll be
done with this entire band website let's
first start by going into our HTML and
adding some classes that we can select
these elements with first we'll use the
class here of cart total that will wrap
our total and the price of the total and
we'll also use class here of cart total
title so this is going to be the title
of total and then in here we have the
class of cart total price since this is
the actual total price and then inside
of our Styles dot CSS we can select
those so we have cart total which is the
row that wraps all of these we'll give
that a text a line of the end so that
our text will go to the end of the line
here just as it does over here and then
we can use the selector for our cart
total title in order to change the
actual text here of this the first thing
we want to do is make the
font-weight:bold
since it is bolded in our design let's
go change that to bulb will increase the
font size to 1.5 en make the color black
so it stands out and we'll give it a
little bit of margin on the right side
is that way it'll be spaced away from
our actual price and we'll just say 20
pixels for that and if we save that
that's starting to look a lot like over
here which is great
last thing we need to do is just style
the actual total price so we can use
cart total price to select that and give
it a color that's slightly darker and a
slightly larger font size just so it
sticks out a little bit more of the
point one am if you say that this now
looks almost exactly the same as this
but you'll notice that our total is very
scrunched up here against the bar so we
just want to add a little bit of margin
so we'll say margin on the top here from
our cart total is going to be 10 pixel
we'll also add a margin on the right of
10 pixels so that our total isn't
squashed right up against the edge of
our screen and instead of has a little
bit extra space and that looks great
right there our card section is now
exactly is over here the only thing we
have left to do is this purchase button
which would be fairly simple since most
of the classes we have are already
defined let's go back to our store at
HTML here we can remove this div that
wraps this section since we don't
actually need that and inside of here
we can add some classes a button and
button primary since this has a primary
colored button and we'll also add a
class of button purchase since this is
going to be a purchase button if we save
that you'll see that we already here
styled here from the primary button
class and if we go into our Styles dot
CSS we can add some Styles specifically
for this purchase button here the first
thing we want to do change the display
to block here so that way we can Center
this button by using auto margins so
we'll use a margin here on the top we
want 40 pixels to space it away from our
total section on the Left we want auto
margin on the bottom we want 80 pixels
and on the right we want another auto
margin and if we save that to see that
our purchase button is now centered with
padding or margin I mean on the top and
an even larger margin on the bottom to
put it away from the footer the last
thing we want to do is increase the font
size to 1.75 e/m so that there's a much
larger button and there we go that looks
great and that's a huge button for them
to click when they want to purchase
their items now all we need to do is
style the footer down here and this is
going to be very easy all we can do is
go into our index page here we can copy
our footer since we know it's exactly
the same and we can just paste that into
our store HTML and if we save that we
now have the footer down here and it
looks amazing this looks exactly as the
page over here and as we increase the
size of our browser our elements will
flow naturally around each other you'll
see all of our columns stay lined up
here no matter how large or how small
our browser is everything looks great
and that's pretty much all there is to
in this store page for our band website
I really hope you guys were able to
learn something from this video thank
you guys very much